The 8th January 1835 is the only day in history
that the USA had no national debt.
In the 19th and early 20th centuries, having
all your teeth removed and replaced with false
ones was a popular 21st-birthday present.
The UK's Dyslexia Research Centre is in Reading.
There are more living organisms in a teaspoonful
of soil than there are people on Earth, and
a billion times more in a tonne than there
are stars in the Milky Way.
The 10,000 trillion ants in the world weigh
about the same as all the human beings.
The US tax code is four times as long as the
complete works of Shakespeare.
All the batteries on Earth store just ten
minutes of the world's electricity needs.
Ancient Greek democracy lasted for only 185
years.
The average person walks the equivalent of
three times around the world in a lifetime.
The United States of America maintains a military
presence in 148 of the 192 United Nations
countries.
More than 50% of NASA employees are dyslexic,
but are hired for their superior problem-solving
and spatial-awareness skills.